hello everyone and welcome to a really
remarkable game from the 22nd European
Team Championship it's the match Russia
vs. Germany on board for the Neil dooble
versus Erasmus wing and it's a we
haven't had a game this good in a while
so I'm sure gonna enjoy it a lot we have
requested it already and it's not I
think it wasn't it wasn't so long ago
that Magnus Carlsen said that he's not
easily inspired by by anyone but that he
is inspired when it comes to chess by
alpha zero okay everyone's inspired by
alpha zero but also by by the creativity
of Daniel Du Bois so let's see what he
what he meant by this we have C 4 by
dubov opening up within the English with
East 6 Knight to c3
we have d5 and d4 so already transposing
into the Queens gambit declined Knight
to f6
we have Knight to f3 and Bishop to e7
Bishop - for pretty standard stuff with
castles III and b6 now preparing to
develop the LightSquared Bishop Queen to
c2 and now Bishop to a6 and here is
already where things are getting
interesting this is a known position
there are no moves like Knight to e5 is
known C captor son d5 is known offering
a trade of light square Bishop b3 is
known just strengthening the the c-4
square but here dubov goes for Queen
side castles so as of move eight already
we have a completely new game so let's
see what's the idea behind the queenside
castle and the why wasn't it played
before since it's only move eight we
have d captures on c4 by Rasmus and now
what what did white gain b5 is nicely
protected so black might even just go B
5 B 4 and start an attack on the Queen
side but the dubov goes Knight to g5 and
okay it's a move definitely probably
hoping for h h6 and h4 and even though
it the engines will give that black has
the advantage here you don't want to
face dubov in a position like this
because if he played it he probably has
all of the variations worked out over
the board I mean at home and then you're
just gonna burn a lot of your time and
if you play suboptimal moves
you don't play perfect moves you're
gonna be in a lot of trouble very soon
so that's one of the ideas the other
ideas just ignore it maybe start the
attack with B 5 B 4 but Swain just
continues development nights the c6 what
ideas of maybe going United before
harassing the Queen a bit so a three by
do both preventing this and now g6 and
here H four just continuing the attack
on the King side and here you could go
for Knight to d5 it makes sense puts
pressure on the night here
attacks the Bishop on f4 but then you
have to calculate Knight captures on h7
and that's that's just an ugly move to
calculate for example after King
captures you go h5 there's the pin here
so you are unable to capture here and
for example after King moves H captures
F characters you run into better to h6
and it just doesn't look good for black
even though it might be playable you
kind of think that dubov had all of this
already at home in his in his
preparation so Bishop to d6 by Swain
instead now offering a trade of the
bishops and the now comes g3 saying that
I don't mind it is I'm just gonna
capture with the pawn here and push h5
later we have Queen to e7 developing the
Queen now connecting rooks and here Du
Bois just continues the attack we have
h5 and this is just going all out full
barbarian mode Michael tal will be proud
of course the the pawn cannot be
captured you don't want to capture with
the Jeep on messing up your pawn
structure and if you capture with the
night it's basically a free night since
you cannot capture it due to Queen
captures on h7 mate so h h5 definitely a
good move
and now Swain replies with E 5 so what's
happening here first eight chapters in
g6 with H captors and g6 and now just a
nice developing move Bishop to g2
trading bishop for a knight here as the
knight on c6 is undefended we have a
captures on f4 Bishop captures on c6
attacking the rook and here it's very
it's very difficult to actually save the
rook for example if you try to move it
let's say rook a d8 you will run into a
lot of trouble after G captors and f4
white is now planning f5 and black
doesn't have a good
move so pretty much any move you play
here it's a bad move there are no useful
moves for black here it's just a
beautiful position for example you might
try King g7 if you can get rook to a
trait in you you will probably be okay
but here Knight to d5 this is the this
is a theme in this game that black will
constantly have to worry about point is
you want to get rid of the defender of
the h7 square which is the f6 Knight so
after night you have to capture it so
after Knight characters you're just
gonna go rook to h7 check King to g8 and
now you're gonna play rook captures on
f7 so here rook captures Queen captures
and g6 King to f8 and now Queen to h6
with check Brooke is gonna block in the
now night to h7 check just going all out
here King to g8 and an out Bishop
captures on d5 will come again with
check King to h8 and now well it's just
a nice meeting tonight to f8 check a
discovery from the Queen rope to h7
blocking and now tonight the G's g6 will
be a nice modern mate as the the king
has nowhere to go
the bishop covers g8 so just one of the
lines that shows how difficult it is to
actually save the rook so here Erasmus
doesn't even try it he plays F captures
and g3 hoping to give up the exchange
after all he will get a very nice pawn
here but dubov plays a wonderful
attacking move he plays King to be one
king to be one with the idea he wants to
play f4 but he doesn't want to allow
Queen captures on e3 to come with check
so first king of the b1 and now swing
goes Luke a to d8 he tries to save the
roof now but it's still very difficult
with f4 by white and now Bishop this
rush back to c8
just regrouping the the defensive pieces
we have root DT one now
just defending the the e3 pawn and first
King to g7 now black is hoping for Luke
to h8 but of course as soon as scheme to
g7 explained above goes for Knight to d5
with the same idea you want to remove
the defender of the h7 square so Knight
captures on d5 and the now rook to h7
with check we have King to g8 and the
now rook captures on f7
so here is a very interesting
in the game because here black had the
opportunity to defend properly and it's
almost always when when someone is
attacking you with with a crazy attack
there's always this one window of
opportunity where you are able to defend
but it's never easy to find so here if
you want to try it out feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
defensive resource for black it's not
easy you know if you want to so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations this time it's a move
with the knight forward so this time
it's Knight to c3 check and it's it's
just one of those weird moves that
actually saves black because he will
either deflect the Queen from attacking
the g6 bond which is crucial to the
attack or you will help a white mess up
his pawn structure which will come in
handy for example after B captures on c3
only now you capture here and now after
Queen captures in g6 with Chuck King to
f8 quinta you don't get anything by
trading here you're down material so
Queen h6 check rook the g7 out and now
there is no knight on d5 so you could
just play a slow move with Bishop to d5
then black is able to regroup with
Bishop to f5 check or you could go for
night to h7 check King to f7 and now you
don't have any any good attacking moves
left if you go mushroom d5 you can just
escape here it's not a problem and if
you try Knight back to g5 to go for some
sort of a perpetual then the rook
captures it will be sufficient F
captures and Bishop the f5 check efore
and queen 36 now I know this is all
crazy stuff to find over the board but
it was it was possible you know as it
always is when there's a when there's a
flashy attack going on so here you
either trade or you try something like
Queen h5 check rush from g6 block and
you defend you are up a piece ok white
still has a very scary Center but you
are able to play this game you have a
passed pawn in g3 you can capture on a3
it's black who would be winning here if
the game continued in in this matter but
here after rook captures on f7 Erasmus
did not find Knight to c3 check he
played rook captures on f7 and now it's
a bit different we have Queen captures
Ang's
wit check King to f8 and now Queen th
sex with check with rock to g7 blocking
and now best shot captures on d5 now you
have to grab the piece with Bishop
captures on d5 we have King to be 8 now
trying to use this square square to
escape but now Queen back to h5 with
check we have King to d7 and now Queen
to h3 with check here we have a
repetition King te 8 and now Queen to h5
check King to d7 and here
dubov does not want to repeat moves he's
not happy with the draw so here he plays
Bishop to e6 check and this is just well
this is just crazy here it's a beautiful
moment really really a beautiful moment
because here there is only one good move
for black and it's actually the Queen
captures on e6 you have to give up the
Queen here tonight capture skin captures
and after f5 check you go King to e7 and
you continue playing this game where you
would have rook and two bishops two
bishops for a queen so white would white
would have a easier game here due to the
wide open King but still if you are able
to get one good move in to consolidate
your pieces you should be ok here with
black however black decided to play King
to c6 and now we entered the position
from the thumbnail and here it's
actually a forced mate in 13 and black
isn't greedy for not giving up the Queen
it's a forced mate in 13 with absolute
perfect play from white so white has a
unique set of moves that allow you to
mate in 13 it's just amazing stuff if
you want feel free to pause the video
it's great for you know working working
on your calculation power if you want to
find this mate in 13 so feel free to
pause the video and try to find it while
I give you a few seconds or you know a
minute or half an hour so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations I am awarding you a more
fee head and also do both is being
awarded the morphe head as this is just
this is just great stuff so here Queen
to f3 with check you could also go Queen
to h1 check but then black and prolong
with GT so Queen to f3
just faster if we're if we're gonna go
for the quickest possible mate with kink
the b5 this is the only move
now comes the only way to continue the
attack Bishop captures on c4 with check
and now if you capture the bishop then
you allow Queen c6 check bushel blocks
and now rook the c1 with check King to
d3 and now you continue the attack we
have looked the c3 with check King to e2
now Queen GT with check King to d1 or e1
doesn't really matter and rook the c1
will be checkmate
so after Bishop to c4 you cannot capture
the bishop you have to go to a five with
Kinte a5 and now Queen to d5 with check
Bishop to c5 blocking and now before
with check the bishop cannot capture so
the King has to go down the board with
King to a4 and now Queen to g2 again a
unique move threatening Queen to c2 mate
so whoever found all of this from from
the start of King to c6 definitely
deserves a more he had with Bishop
captures and before now at least
clearing the a5 square for the black
King but now Queen back the c6 width
check now if King a5 just win b5 is made
so you have to go down the board King
captures on a3 and now again another
unique move you had to find all the way
from that position is Bishop to b3 and
just to show you for example rookie 2
followed by a rook to a2 will be made
problem is black has for example Bishop
to d2 he will just slow down your attack
and once you capture Queen before check
already black is now on the attack
for example King see c1 or c2 now Bishop
the f5 with check King to d1 now you
continue Quinta a4 check you are already
able to trade Queens and now you just
enjoy this position being up material
and already having a passed pawn and g3
you have a passed point here you can
start pushing it it's just winning for
black so here
Bishop to b3 another unique move now
threatens Queen to a4 mate and if King
after Sun b3 then it's just Queen c2
check King has to move and Queen to a2
will be mate
so after Bishop to b3 we have Bishop to
d7 the chapter 5 check is
made by e4 so it's not a problem the
shop the d7 prevents Quinte for mate but
now you get the other mate queen the c1
with check now basically forcing black
to capture the bishop kink after Sun B 3
and now Queen the CT with check King to
a3 and now followed by Queen to a2 mate
so this all happened on the board so I
will also like to congratulate Swain for
allowing me to happen on the board which
is not something everyone would do so
really just amazing stuff looking at
this King on a3 the King started his
journey on g8 just you know just to
illustrate this so it's really
remarkable how the black King found
himself on a3 and yeah I do hope you
agree that this game deserves the morphe
head as it's just it is amazing 13 with
the absolute best play from black so
maybe maybe here it was a the mate
happened a bit sooner because black did
not play all the you know optimal
defensive resources but if it's a force
mate is a force mate you're not gonna
get any points for making it last longer
but they're just a unique set of moves
everything that was just was just really
amazing so once again I would like to
congratulate all of you for finding it
and receiving the morphe head we can we
can take it away now but yeah really an
amazing game and one of you can see that
one of the reasons why Magnus Carlsen is
inspired by Daniel dubov he always plays
a really creative chest and his games
are always you know just a full of
fireworks so yeah yeah that's the game I
don't know how Germany fared against the
rush ROM as someone game was still being
played the vehicle versus NEC piano so I
don't know how that game ended on board
one I'm sure it was a very interesting
game as well but we'll probably check
out one more game from this front so
we're gonna check out the standings so
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Tony Moore the
guitar for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot
Tony Tony what has been one of the first
contributors to the channel ever since I
started so I'm very happy to see that
you are still enjoying the show thank
you sir
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the world official random
championship continuing to check up nice
games like this one from the European
Team Championship and of course checking
up on your suggestions so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day